all right it uh
that
i am really really frustrated with uh
what i'm about to tell you
we have been banned from facebook's
video monetization for 90 days 90 days
because of
anti-vaxx content now i know all of you
are probably saying wait david
antivax what on earth are you talking
about you have been following the
science on vaccines and explaining the
effectiveness of these vaccines in the i
know
i know believe me but we have been
banned from facebook's monetization for
90 days and i'm going to explain to you
why in a second now the back story here
of course is
we
know
that at the flip of a switch we can lose
entire sources of revenue for our
program how do we know that because it's
happened
adpocalypse took place in april of 2017
when as a result of an ad playing on a
racist youtube video that had nothing to
do with us
youtube and advertisers essentially
switched off advertising on news and
politics content for close to two months
we lost
99.98 of our youtube revenue for nearly
two months
and that made us realize we've got to
diversify we've got to diversify that's
why we started streaming on twitch
that's why we started posting all of our
content to facebook instead of just a
clip or two a day
now about a year ago we lost
monetization
for seven days from facebook and we
never found out why we were told you
violated community guidelines well which
which post couldn't find out what did we
say couldn't find out but it was only
seven days so we just decided to wait it
out but we were told
if this happens again and it's like if
what happens again if this happens again
you will lose monetization for 90 days
now because we have decided to diversify
revenue sources
because of what's happened in the past
facebook has grown to be close to 20
of our revenue
and we have now lost that 20
for three months
what is the post that caused this
i will show it to you
we covered
early last week
the
conflict between alex jones and donald
trump
donald trump now has been advocating
more
more more publicly for the vaccine
alex jones is anti-vaccine and turned on
donald trump so we posted
is this where trump's base is going to
draw the line and we linked to our video
alex jones loses it on trump jones
against vaccine trump pro this is
creating a rift and of course the things
alex jones said in the video gene
therapies killing people we said all of
these things are lies
that got us banned from facebook
monetization for 90 days 90 days
um
this is
close to 20 of our revenue now
and of course
it is a complete and total
misunderstanding we aren't anti-vaxx now
i know there are people who are going to
hear this i already i'm imagining the
comments on on youtube
david this is your just desserts
this is what you deserve david because
you've been cheering
for people being
cancelled from facebook or youtube or
whatever no no no no no
i hope that some of you are
sophisticated enough to understand what
is going on here
versus what we've talked about in the
past
i am 100
respectful of the fact that facebook
youtube twitter whoever can establish
their terms and conditions for what is
allowed on the platform facebook is
completely right to say we're not gonna
allow the spread of covet disinformation
they still allow it but they are
completely right to say that will be our
policy the problem here isn't that
it's that it's not being applied
correctly we are obviously not an
anti-vaccine show
so all the people oh but david you said
you they they're coming for you now this
is what you deserve no no no
they're not coming for me for anything
we actually did i respect that facebook
can have and enforce terms and
conditions we just didn't violate them
this is a mistake and there's no
recourse to get it reversed there's no
way to get a hold of anyone at facebook
so
if you actually
work or have someone you know that works
at facebook that could help with this
please email info davidpakman.com don't
send me a link to a form where i can
submit if we've done that facebook
doesn't respond to any of that stuff
okay i've reached out to every i asked
jenk yuger hey do you have a contact i
asked our youtube rep it's like why i'm
like listen i know you work for google
not facebook but do you happen to know
anyone at facebook if you actually work
there or know someone who might be able
to help but there is every indication
that for three months
we are losing
uh 20 of our revenue and i know some of
you will say screw facebook we don't
need it
if we
don't work to have our content there
we are giving more space to the actual
right wing disinformation that spreads
uncontrolled on facebook so i know it's
easy to say just get off the platform
the platform is huge and we are on there
to try to fight the trash that is spread
like wildfire on facebook so all i can
ask you is help us make up for that 20
we're gonna lose for three months grab a
membership on my website uh that that
that's really the the one ask i have
um 20 for three months is that's a big
chunk you know we we've got a number of
employees now and a lot of different
things that we're doing and 20 is a big
deal we've created a coupon code it's
kind of a joke it's facebook with two fs
you know f facebook okay yeah that's
it's a joke okay but um you can go to
joinpakman.com
use the code facebook you'll get a
discount and hopefully we can make up a
little bit of this lost 20 but an
absolutely
devastating thing devastating thing and
i'll keep people posted about it you can
support the david pakman show by
supporting our sponsors and one of those
sponsors is sheath underwear
traditional underwear involves sticking
sweating the dreaded chafing sheath
underwear are boxer briefs
specifically designed to keep everything
separate
cool dry and comfortable they have a
bunch of great designs options to choose
from more minimal styles their signature
geometric pattern waistband is cool
there's really something for everybody
but the most important thing is you stay
cool during the day and at night
upping your comfort to the next level
read the reviews online sheath underwear
has been a game changer for many men
give it a try they have super fast
shipping you'll get your order in just a
few days and don't forget that you'll
get 20 off when you go to sheath
dot com slash pacman and use the code
pacman the link is down below